a vaccine may be with us but it comes
with a flare-up in the age-old struggle
with
anti-vaxxers whose damaging narratives
appear to be growing in strength no
vaccine's ever been proven safe and no
vaccine has ever been proven effective
we know that's not true please allow me
to
millions and millions of lives have been
saved by vaccines some of the safest
medicines
ever invented that's just nonsense kate
shemaranis emerged as a spokesperson for
the extreme movement
spreading falsehoods about vaccination
and despite nearly one and a half
million deaths worldwide
she even claims there's no health crisis
there is no
evidence that i can see that a pandemic
exists
there is no evidence that sars cove 2
has been purified and is unequivocally
in existence it is easy to dismiss such
views
as the prime minister has done because
there's all these anti-vaxxers now isn't
it
well mourinho can tell you a little bit
about how we but there is concern
anti-vaxx propaganda grounded in
conspiracy theory
and pseudoscience is undermining
confidence
i think it's really important that we
stay clear of this
sort of skeptical gossip manga in social
media
i think it's important that we really
look at the expert opinion
and it's clear the public does need
reassurance
on the high street in tunbridge wells in
tier three they're excited about the
vaccine rollouts
but there's also nervousness i'm not an
anti-vaxxer i'm fully vaccinated and so
is my daughter but it is something that
i'm gonna have to consider
i probably have to trust them i mean i
take all my medications
with the trust of my doctors they give
me something this works for you
and i'll probably try it stop this
needless death
in the past it was easier for the
government to get its message across
immunization does not hurt public health
broadcasts though
now have to compete with social media
where fake news about vaccines
can go viral quickly there was a very
damaging video
about spreading misinformation about the
vaccines and about the pandemic
featuring bill gates and others you know
discussing him
and that actually went viral very
quickly professor melinda mills
at oxford university says the government
needs to do more
if it's to win against the scare stories
what you need in order for people to
take vaccines you need trust
and how do you gain trust you gain trust
from being transparent
we better get moving now and we better
be clear
because otherwise rumors can go viral
you know we're not just facing a
pandemic right now we're facing an
infodemic
there's no doubt the vaccine rollout is
a major breakthrough
quite literally a shot in the arm in the
medical fight against covid19
but make no mistake lancing the boil of
misinformation
and fake news will be just as important
in the days and weeks to come alex rossi
sky news